alors ça va très bien comment qu'est ce
qui est arrivé il a pourrait expliquer
nous
simplement quoi il y avait une fuite ont
croyons on n'a pas pris de chance qu est
ce qui est arrivé ce matin mais
c'est la première fois que ce système
est au complet et essayer tout assemblé
et pas l'équipage à bord c'est plus
comme une répétition générale avant les
premières missions habitées
donc on s'attendait un pur du monde
récemment je suis ravi qu'elle avait de
grandes chances que quelqu'un trouve un
problème qui le voit comme ça c'est
presque rassurant ça veut dire que ces
milliers d'ingénieurs leur porter
attention à leurs affaires et ils ré
problème qui peut être résolu plusieurs
produits de la vicomté résolu à parent
il y avait la foule demande et parce que
ça a retardé le début du top 100 du
carburant y aura les crédits une fuite
mais finalement ça a été résolu ils
proviennent de communication des crânes
et des os a été résolu et puis l'heure
dans les minutes qui ont précédé
lancement il y avait un des quatre
moteurs puis ce pot qui a je vais pas
arriver à température désirée c'était
pas clair pourquoi je te justin détecte
un terme au mal qui marchent pas
vraiment un problème lyon décidé dans le
rapport à propos nation il faut que ça
marche pour ses missions là c'est une
histoire a pris tellement tellement
compliqué difficile dangereux tout ce
pouvoir maintenant des quelque 1 17
nexar marche et malheureusement c'est
pas aujourd'hui vendredi c'est la
première prochaine fenêtre sont eux qui
sous la lune poquelin anciennes et
entrave on veut dans le travail des
seniors ont réussi à aller au fond du
problème gastrique
cette fois ça a marché rendez vous
vendredi mais d'être finie vous aviez su
mais oui mais comme vous dites c'est
rassurant aussi vous savez j'ai comprend
aucune charge pourquoi la fenêtre et si
et si petit comme ça parce que la lune
oui à bout jeumont peut changer la
trajectoire non oui effectivement voté
pour un stadiste est aujourd'hui c'est
deux ans ok deux heures de marche pour
une version pour ajuster le tir au
restaurant car elle se sent le podcast
est infini de carburant c'est au tour
contre un faux pas que le vaisseau
spatial passe dans l'ombre la taille ces
panneaux solaires composant de criticité
toute contrainte pour retour veux penser
dans deux semaines à venir
je n'ai un calendrier un peu compliqué
mais aujourd'hui on avait 200 roubles
prochain bloc ces deux ans vraiment
pourquoi
david saint jacques on retourne bon là
justement voir tourner autour de la lune
artemis 2 sera habitée par des
astronautes on va aussi faire des
rotations autour de la lune pourquoi on
fait ça et avant lé là dessus précise et
atterrissent de avec un équipage non
seulement il va avoir un astronaute
canadien oisienne ça c'est ma dernière
avoue mais bon j'aimerais tout de suite
est-ce que ça soit vous allez le rsa
mais est on est on est on est quatre
astronautes actif au sein de la société
indienne ce genre destination l'heure
c'est fait résultat de grosses
collaboration internationale pour
générer le meilleur tirage possible
manière globale avec toutes les
aptitudes pour maximiser les succès de
la mission tout le monde doit être
impliqué évidemment il ya plupart des
gens vont travailler en coulisses sur ce
qui va être sur scène on verra on verra
sa compagne électorale
c'est pour résultat d'apporter un
concours de popularité
vous serez peut-être
être à bord bien sur wii camaret et qui
quand j'étais à bord nationale puis je
regardais la terre parce micropole
niveau j'en avais la lune et puis des
fois cette semaine auprès
des gens qu'on voit sur paris restreinte
et grands mais expliquez moi 22 charron
pourquoi on retourne sur la lune en
italie à 50 ans avec apollo
oui c'est l'instinct générer la sauver
la génération paulo va toujours que ça
impressionné les quarts et axa re
motiver
maintenant si la génération are tennis
on retourne sur une mais pour y rester
cette fois ci à long terme pour faire
une station en orbite autour d'al une
calebasse sur la lune et tout ça c'est
un peu pour apprendre à ces précieux on
peut vivre dans l'espace de manière plus
prolongé pour un prêt sans oser aller
vers mars donc tout ça fait partie de
cette ambition complètement folle d'un
jour mettre les souriceaux mars qui sont
peut-être des jeunes et des enfants
encore tu avais saint-jacques toujours
un plaisir de vous parler merci beaucoup
de soirée battant mois